tena on sera tous merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi sur notre antenne l'examen
par les sénateurs du projet de loi qui
autorise le gouvernement à légiférer par
ordonnances pour accélérer la
construction de logements objectif de ce
texte présenté cet après midi par la
ministre cécile duflot lever certains
obstacles administratifs afin
d'autoriser notamment la surélévation de
certains bâtiments pour créer des
logements accélérer la délivrance de
permis de construire ou encore favoriser
la transformation de bureaux en
logements
alors pour en savoir plus sur ce texte
direction l'hémicycle bonne science à
tous mes chers collègues l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion du projet de loi
adopté par l'assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
habilitant le gouvernement à légiférer
pour accélérer les projets de
construction dans la discussion générale
la parole est à mme ren cécile duflot
ministre de l'égalité des territoires et
du logement
la parole d'un ministre
et
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
nous étions convenus l'hiver dernier de
nous revoir à l'automne prochain pour
examiner une loi relative à l'urbanisme
et au logement qui serait déposée à
l'été
ce rendez vous aura bien lieu mais nous
en avons un autre aujourd'hui un rendez
vous avancez qui nous permettra si vous
l'acceptez de faire en sorte d'habilité
le gouvernement à prendre par voie
d'ordonnancé des dispositions qui dans
une période difficile permettront
d'accélérer les projets de construction
je n'ignore pas mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs que le terme
ordonnance n'a pas tout à fait sa place
au panthéon sémantique des
parlementaires j'appartiens comme vous
le savez à une tradition politique qui
est extrêmement attaché au respect des
droits et de l'indépendance du parlement
et c'est parce que la situation
l'exigent
sans aucune hésitation et aussi parce
que nous avons travaillé longuement sur
le projet de loi que je viendrai vous
présenter bientôt que je vous présente
ce projet de loi d'habilitation afin que
vous permettiez au gouvernement de
légiférer par ordonnance oui il est
certain que nous devons collectivement
prendre nos responsabilités devant
l'urgence et la violence de la crise qui
touche le secteur de la construction de
la manière la plus rapide et la plus
volontaire qui soit nous devons lever
les obstacles qui obère les chances de
notre pays de répondre aux besoins qui
sont les siens j'ai vu la semaine passée
à l'assemblée qu'une telle volonté n'est
pas sans bousculer conviction et
certitudes
je n'ignore pas que sur les membres de
la haute chambre sont également les
inquiétudes
il appartient au gouvernement de les
entendre et d'y répondre mais si j'ai
accepté de relever ce défi devant et
avec vous c'est aussi parce que je crois
à notre capacité collective de dégager
un accord solide et pérenne qui
répondent à l'impérieuse obligation de
construire des logements
c'est un cycle
répondront un triple enjeu un enjeu
social un enjeu économique
un enjeu environnemental un enjeu social
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion le souligner à
de nombreuses reprises devant vous parce
que la pénurie de logements est une
menace pour notre cohésion sociale parce
que trois millions et demi de personnes
dans notre pays en 2013 mal logés c'est
insupportable
je sais que vous êtes également en tant
qu'élus locaux confrontés à cette
insupportable réalité le droit au
logement n'est pas garanti dans les
faits dans notre pays
c'est pourtant et ce devrait être un
droit inaliénable
nous nous employons depuis les premières
minutes de notre arrivée à le défendre
nous entendons la demande l'impatience
et parfois la colère qui monte de notre
pays
l'inaction où l'attentisme n'est pas un
luxe que nous pouvons nous offrir ce
serait une faute
faciliter et encourager la construction
c'est également un enjeu économique au
coeur de notre bataille en faveur de
l'emploi et de notre et de nos efforts
au service de l'action face à la crise
les secteurs de la construction besoins
de notre mobilisation en faveur du
logement ils en ont besoin maintenant et
rapidement construire des logements
s'est enfin et vous le savez un enjeu
environnemental
nous devons défendre la ville dense pour
lutter contre l'étalement urbain
l'artificialisation des sols et donc la
destruction la disparition des terres
agricoles
l'urgence de la construction de
logements est compatible avec la
protection de l'environnement
il faut de la nature en ville pour faire
droit à la biodiversité rendre la
doublette densité non seulement
acceptable mais aussi souhaitable c'est
la densité urbaine qui permet les
services et les équipements qui permet
les réseaux c'est la nature en ville qui
préserve les respirations et la qualité
du cadre de vie
il faut à la fois plus de logements et
plus de logements de qualité
c'est d'ailleurs le sens des politiques
que nous aurons à conduire au service de
la rénovation énergétique
vous l'aurez compris si le président de
la république a souhaité procéder par
ordonnance c'est pour utiliser toutes
les possibilités d'accélération que le
droit nous offre le projet de loi que je
présente ce jour devant vous est l'un
des fruits du plan d'investissement pour
le logement annoncé le 21 mars
son objectif est très simple il consiste
à lever aussi vite que possible
les principaux freins identifiés à la
construction de logements
ce sont des dispositions financières
parfois techniques qui permettront de
lever ces freins essentiellement due à
l'empilement des procédures la
complexité des dispositifs et l'absence
de lisibilité d'ensemble du droit de
l'urbanisme
en adoptant ce projet de loi
d'habilitation vous permettrait pour
certaines de ses dispositions de gagner
sans doute plus d'un an dans l'eure dans
leur mise en application
dans la situation dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons c'est cette année
supplémentaire sera une année absolument
décisive pour les professionnels et pour
les français
l'habilitation que je vous demande
aujourd'hui cible une série sujets
identifiés lors des vastes concertation
menée à l'occasion de la loi sur le
logement et l'urbanisme qu'il sera
bientôt déposé sur le bureau du
parlement
je voulais présenterait en détail
lorsque chacune d'elles fera l'objet
d'un débat lors de cette séance mais je
souhaite à ce stade vous dire un mot
rapide sur chacune d'entre elles une
mesure de cohérence d'abord les
professionnels les élus mais aussi les
citoyens se plaignent de l'empilement
dans le temps des procédures pour
construire des logements
le gouvernement vous propose donc de
l'habilité pour bâtir une procédure
intégré pour le logement qui fusionnent
et paralyse les délais plutôt que de les
compiler les uns à la suite des autres
il s'agit d'accélérer les procédures
sans y déroger vos collègues députés ont
souhaité préciser que cette nouvelle
procédure devrait obéir un objectif de
mixité sociale et fonctionnelle des
projets
une mesure de transparence ensuite il
vous est ainsi proposé d'améliorer
l'accès aux documents d'urbanisme à
travers la création d'un portail
national de l'urbanisme ou
professionnels comme particuliers
pourront trouver les renseignements
utiles pour déterminer plus aisément la
constructibilité d'un terrain est donc
envisagé plus facilement les projets aux
endroits les plus importants j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion lors de mon audition
monsieur le président devant la
commission des affaires économiques de
rassurer celles et ceux qui
s'inquiétaient d'un surcoût pour les
petites collectivités
il appartiendra à l'état d'être
l'initiateur et le garant de ce guichet
unique d'information sur l'urbanisme en
france l'état en assumera donc les coûts
de développement et de déploiement en
ligne
avec l'hygiène le budget prévisionnel
est ainsi de 3 millions et demi sur
trois ans par ailleurs certains
territoires ont déjà mis en place un
portail local de l'urbanisme leur
expérience permettra d'alimenter les
modalités de portage et d'accompagnement
en particulier vis-à-vis des petites
collectivités
une troisième mesure est une mesure de
mobilisation de tous les acteurs pour
faciliter le financement de projets
d'aménagement il est proposé de
permettre je dis bien de permettre aux
collectivités d'augmenter le taux
maximal de garantie d'emprunt qu'elles
peuvent consentir
je tiens donc bien a précisé qu'il
s'agit d'une possibilité ouverte aux
collectivités en aucun cas d'une
obligation
les élus qui considérons que cette
augmentation du taux maximal le garantie
d'emprunt ferait peser un risque trop
lourd sur leur collectivité ne seront en
aucun cas forcé d'y recourir en revanche
ceux qui souhaitent pouvoir disposer de
cette option pour pouvoir faciliter
l'aboutissement de projets qui sont
rendus plus difficiles du fait du
renchérissement des garanties bancaires
auront la possibilité de le faire ce que
la loi leur interdit aujourd'hui une
mesure démocratique
ensuite en tant qu'élus locaux vous avez
été confrontés à des recours qu'il n'est
pas sans mauvais jeu de mots abusif de
qualifier de mafieux tout le monde
s'accorde à dire aujourd'hui qu'il est
urgent de réduire le délai de traitement
des recours contentieux et de lutter
contre ces recours de type mafieux qui
se multiplient notamment dans certains
territoires de notre république contre
les permis de construire une ordonnance
sera prise dans 16 autres dans cet
objectif elle se fondera sur les
conclusions du rapport que m'a remis le
président aulas pfuhl juriste et grand
spécialiste de ces questions
je souhaite vous en dire précisément
quelques mots pour lutter contre les
recours regardé comme abusif je
proposerai que soient précisées
l'intérêt à agir des personnes pour que
soit ce soit bien des motifs liés à
l'urbanisme qui soit susceptible de
motiver ses recours
j'envisage aussi d'ouvrir aux titulaires
du permis de construire une action en
dommages et intérêts contre l'auteur du
recours en cas de préjudice à normale
liée à l'introduction de ce dernier
cette proposition est un moyen de
dissuasion très fort pour être juste il
faut évidemment qu'elle vise
exclusivement les recours malveillants
sans fondement autre qu'un intérêt
financier une troisième proposition qui
sera sans doute très forte consiste à
déclarer auprès de l'administration
des impôts les transactions qui
aboutissent un désistement monnayer du
recours contre un permis de construire
sous peine de nullité de la transaction
je pense que le pouvoir dissuasif de
l'administration fiscale freinera ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui fait profession si
on peut utiliser ce terme des recours
contre les permis de construire pour
raccourcir les délais de traitement des
recours la quatrième proposition sans
doute parmi les plus puissantes
consistera à donner la possibilité au
juge de fixer une date au delà de
laquelle de nouveaux moyens d'annulation
du permis ne pourront plus être invoqué
on ne pourra plus égrainé les moyens en
gardant les entre guillemets meilleur
pour la fin
dans le seul but de ralentir sans fin la
durée de la procédure ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui
une autre proposition pour accélérer le
traitement des recours c'est celle de
donner aux cours administratives d'appel
une compétence de premier et de dernier
ressort afin d'accélérer les procédures
pour les projets de tailles importantes
notamment ceux d'une surface supérieure
à 1500 mètres carrés situés dans les
communes où le déséquilibre entre
l'offre et la demande et marqué les
agglomérations de plus de 50000
habitants soumises à la taxe sur les
logements vacants
avec cette procédure on peut diviser par
trois les durées traitement des
contentieux les plus lourds comme vous
le voyez j'ai souhaité pouvoir vous
présenter dorje d'ores et déjà quelles
sont les dispositions précises envisagée
dans le cadre des ordonnances qui seront
adoptées suite à un vote de ce projet de
loi d'habilitation
mais et je souhaite leur dire devant
vous ce travail de se poursuivra en
concertation avec les parlementaires
pour avancer sur ce dossier très
compliqué sur lequel mon prédécesseur
s'était engagé devant vous a publié un
décret puis décret qu'il n'a pas publié
en ayant évidemment pas la possibilité
je pense qu'il est nécessaire que ce que
ces avancées puissent être concertés
pour être immédiatement approprié parce
qu'ils ont besoin que se lève ses délais
de recours qui fige parfois des parties
de ville dans des situations absolument
inconfortable de début de chantier
interrompu voire même de terrain vide et
inutilisés pendant des années une autre
propose une autre des dispositions
proposées par le projet de loi
d'habilitation et celui de se donner les
moyens de densifier la ville ce débat
avait eu lieu au moment de l'abrogation
de la disposition univoque sur la
constructibilité augmenté de 30% j'avais
dit que c'était un sujet nécessaire que
nous reviendrons sur ces questions et
qu'il fallait à l'issue de la
concertation qui notamment été menées
par les professionnels trouver des
dispositions qui permettent aux élus
d'intervenir dans la dentelle et pas de
leur imposer une densification univoque
sur l'ensemble du territoire français
voilà dans ce cadre les mesures que nous
proposons
elles seront susceptibles de lever
rapidement les obstacles à la
densification tout en luttant contre
l'étalement urbain en favorisant la
transformation des bureaux en logements
en limitant les obligations en matière
de places de stationnement en autorisant
un alignement au faîtage ou la
surélévation d'immeubles pour la
création de logements
l'assemblée nationale a souhaité que les
mesures de densification puissent être
prises en fonction de la zone concernée
et du bâti existant et qu'elle
s'inscrive dans un objectif de mixité
sociale
la commission des affaires économiques
de votre assemblée sur proposition du
rapporteur claude bérit-debat a précisé
la rédaction de la disposition de façon
à préserver le pouvoir des maires c'est
effectivement aux élus proximité qu'il
revient de dessiner l'avenir de leur
territoire
mais nous souhaitons leur en donner les
moyens et les outils c'est bien tout
l'esprit et ce sera la lettre de ces
propositions
il vous est enfin proposé d'encourager
le développement de logements
intermédiaires cette offre de logements
fait aujourd'hui cruellement défaut dans
les zones tendues où les loyers du parc
privé atteignent des niveaux inabordable
pour les classes moyennes
cette absence d'une offre intermédiaire
entre le parc public et le parc privé
contribue à gripper les parcours
résidentiels et nuit à la rotation du
parc social
il sera donc très utile d'y remédier
d'abord en définissant un statut du
logement intermédiaire il devra se
caractériser de façon très claire par un
niveau de loyer intermédiaire comme son
nom l'indiqué entre le parc privé et le
parc public et par un plafond de
ressources pour ses locataires
l'inscription dans les textes du
logement intermédiaire permettra ainsi
aux collectivités territoriales d'en
prévoir la production dans leur document
de planification et de programmation est
également en créant un bail de longue
durée
dédiée à la production de logements
intermédiaires cela permettra aux
acteurs publics de développer une
politique foncière innovantes en faveur
du logement à prix maîtrisés qu'il soit
locatifs ou en accession cette question
avait notamment été évoqué lors du débat
sur
précédent projet de loi portant sur la
cession du foncier public et enfin
troisième élément permettant le
développement de cette offre locative
intermédiaire l'autorisation aux organes
donner aux organismes de logement social
de créer des filiales dédiées à la
production et à la gestion de logements
intermédiaires sur agrément de l'état et
sous des conditions restrictives que
l'assemblée nationale a souhaité écrire
en toutes lettres les députés ont en
effet souhaité ce qu'ils rejoignaient la
volonté du gouvernement mais qui est
désormais écrit dans le projet de loi
posé un principe d'étanchéité entre la
maison mère est la filiale nous avons
donc conjurer tout danger d'éventuels
ponction des fonds du logement social
par le logement intermédiaire il est
ensuite proposé de supprimer la
possibilité de garantie intrinsèque pour
les opérations de ventes de logements en
l'état futur d'achèvement
vous le savez acheter un logement est
une décision lourde de conséquences
financières et qui engage bien souvent
toute une vie bien qu'il s'agisse de cas
peu fréquent
nous ne pouvons pas accepter le drame
que représente pour une famille le fait
de s'être endettés à vie et la banque
continuant de réclamer ces
remboursements pour un logement qu'il
sera jamais livré parfois même à peine
commencée et dont la banque je le dis
continuent de réclamer le paiement
c'est le risque que fait courir et qu'a
fait courir et c'est le risque avéré
pour un certain nombre de ménages que
comprend la garantie intrinsèque c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous souhaitons
sa suppression progressive
je n'ignore pas cependant que cette
évolution remet en cause le modèle
économique de certains promoteurs dont
un grand nombre font un travail tout à
fait honnête il est donc proposé une
application progressive de cette mesure
est un travail sera mené avec les
assureurs et la profession pour veiller
à ce que la garantie extrinsèque soit
proposer au plus grand nombre de
constructeurs
enfin il s'agit également de faciliter
la gestion de la trésorerie des
entreprises du bâtiment
ces dernières dispositions vont
permettre de modifier le cahier des
clauses administratives générales
relatives au marché travaux publics pour
réduire les délais de production du
décompte général après réception des
travaux pour les marchés de travaux
privés il s'agit notamment de prévoir
que le délai d'intervention du maître
d'oeuvre ou d'un autre prestataire dont
l'intervention conditionne
le paiement des sommes dues et désormais
inclus dans le délai de paiement pour
les acomptes mensuels et de s'assurer
que les maîtres d'ouvragé paye chaque
mois les travaux exécutés par les
professionnels de ce secteur
sur la base des demandes de paiement
mensuel qu'il présente
cela semble à ce stade très technique je
peux vous dire que pour des milliers
d'entreprises du secteur du bâtiment ce
sera un bol d'air extrêmement important
et cela évitera des situations de
tensions financières extrêmes l'ensemble
des dispositions que je viens de vous
présenter vise donc très concrètement à
résoudre des difficultés aggravées par
la situation économique du secteur c'est
pourquoi il est urgent de pouvoir les
mettre en oeuvre le plus rapidement
possible elle n'épuise bien sûr pas le
sujet et nous aurons l'occasion de nous
retrouver pour en débattre à nouveau
dans quelques mois
j'espère comme cela a été le cas à
l'assemblée nationale que nous saurons
nous rassemble et peut-être même au-delà
des traditionnels clivages partisans
pour donner le coup d'accélérateur dont
notre pays a besoin dans ce domaine
je peux vous dire que l'ensemble de ces
dispositions qui peuvent apparaître
techniques sont des dispositions
largement concertée largement partagée
qui auront une efficacité rapide pour un
certain nombre d'entre elles et je
voudrais simplement vous rappeler
aujourd'hui qu'il existe environ 5
millions de mètres carrés de bureaux
vacants en france dont une grande partie
dans les zones tendues qui sont
aujourd'hui qui est aujourd'hui
impossible pour des raisons juridiques
de transformer en logement vous imaginez
bien que là aussi la possibilité de
réaliser ces travaux plus rapidement
pourra permettre de contribuer à la fois
à s'attaquer à la crise de ce secteur
mais aussi à la crise du logement
chantier qui vous le savez est loin
d'être clos je sais que les français ont
besoin de vous et qu'il est de notre
devoir il est du devoir du gouvernement
il est de mon devoir de m'appuyer sur
votre mobilisation pour être l'avocate
infatigable de la cause du logement
c'est bien dans cet esprit que je me
tiens devant vous aujourd'hui à la fois
consciente de la gravité des sujets dont
nous discutons et plein d'espoir sur
notre capacité à nous battre avec
énergie contre ce qui n'est pas une
fatalité et qui malheureusement
souffrirait de nos atermoiements
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je vous
remercie
merci madame le ministre
dans la discussion générale la parole et
à monsieur claude bérit débat rapporteur
de la commission des affaires
économiques
madame la ministre monsieur le président
mes chers collègues le recours à la
procédure des ordonnances pour accélérer
la mise en oeuvre de la politique en
matière de construction a été demandée
par le président de la république le 21
mars dernier lors de l'annoncé du plan
d'investissement pour le logement
s'il est évident que cette procédure ne
peut être la méthode habituelle
d'élaboration de la loi
elle peut en revanche se justifier dans
des domaines précisément circonscrit
lorsque les sujets traités se
caractérise par une certaine urgence ou
une grande complicité technique c'est
bien dans ce cas de figure que nous nous
trouvons avec le présent texte comme l'a
rappelé avec justesse madame la ministre
la demande d'habilitation concerne en
effet des mesures à la fois pragmatiques
complexe et en même temps de nature à
lever dans de très brefs délais certains
des frais à la construction de logements
au demeurant je le souligne la
constitution donne au parlement le
pouvoir de contrôle total sur les
objectifs et les principes qui
définissent le champ d'habilitation
donné au gouvernement en l'occurrence
ses contours en d'ores et déjà été
précisée par de nombreux amendements
adoptés lors des débats à l'assemblée
nationale
j'y reviendrai plus loin nos débats
permettront je l'espère d'apporter de
nouvelles précisions utiles je n'en
doute pas j'en proposerai moi même
certaines au nom de la commission des
affaires économiques
pour donner plus de poids au contrôle
exercé par le parlement
je souhaiterais toutefois madame la
ministre que nous puissions être
informés au fur et à mesure des progrès
réalisés dans la rédaction des
ordonnances
de manière à conduire un dialogue
constructif avec l'administration
enfin mes chers collègues je rappelle
que nous aurons aussi un contrôle total
sur le fond sur le texte final des
ordonnances au travers de la procédure
de ratification pour toutes ces raisons
j'approuve sans hésitation le recours à
la procédure des ordonnances dans ce cas
d'espèce
au demeurant ayant été le rapporteur de
la loi sur la mobilisation du foncier en
faveur du logement
je suis bien placé pour témoigner du
rôle central que de pioneer le parlement
a tenu dans la définition et l'impulsion
de la politique du logement
nous avons en effet discuté et voté
plusieurs mesures à la fois concrète et
très ambitieuse renforcement des
obligations en matière de construction
de logements sociaux
mise à disposition des terrains de
l'état pour construire des logements
sociaux augmentation des aides de
lapierre création d'un nouveau
dispositif d'investissement locatif
bon cette liste n'est pas exhaustive
mais elle témoigne d'une implication
totale du parlement sur le sujet du
logement
par ailleurs vous le savez une deuxième
séquence parlementaire s'ouvrira dans
les semaines à venir
au cours de l'été sera déposé un nouveau
projet de loi pour infléchir les
politiques publiques en matière de
logement et d'aménagement d'urbanisme et
ainsi concilier plus harmonieusement
l'objectif de construire davantage et
mieux avec celui de préserver des
espaces naturels et agricoles
là encore le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale exerce seront sans restriction
ni délégation leurs compétences
législatives
c'est donc dans l'intervalle entre ces
deux séquences parlementaire forte les
lois du flower et du faux 2 madame la
ministre
que prend place le projet de loi
d'habilitation certaines des mesures
qu'il envisage permettront d'améliorer
ponctuellement la situation d'autres en
revanche ont une partie plus
structurelle c'est le cas de la
procédure intégré pour le logement
elle permettra et vous l'avez dit de
modifier en soi une fois pardon
l'ensemble des documents d'urbanisme et
des plans et schémas issus de
législation connaissent que lorsqu'ils
font tostat cloud projet de construction
de logements
cela pourrait permettre et nous en avons
parlé longuement de diviser par deux la
durée des procédures des modifications
qu'aujourd'hui s'empiler se répète
c'est le cas aussi pour le géoportail
national d'urbanisme qui permettra à
terme de connaître par une simple
connexion internet
l'ensemble des droits à construire
relatif à une parcelle donné c'est le
cas en fin de la réforme du contentieux
d'urbanisme
c'est une demande ancienne tente de
porteurs de projets tant des porteurs de
projets que des élus locaux
la question avait été abordée notamment
au cours des débats sur la loi du faux
seins nos collègues centristes et je
parle et je pense en particulier à
daniel dubois kif qui est face à moi
avait été très actif sur ce thème
la ministre après avoir indiqué qu'elle
travaillait sur cette question s'était
engagé avancer rapidement des
propositions dans ce domaine
le gouvernement a donc demandé à un
groupe de travail présidé par un
conseiller d'état de lui faire des
propositions et le rapport du président
la boule a été rendue publique au début
du mois et ses propositions apporte des
solutions des solutions que j'estime
innovantes équilibré toutes ces mesures
à la fois très utile est complètement
détachable du futur de projet de loi 2
la rentrée il aurait été ridicule de les
garder dans les tiroirs
alors que leur adoption répond aux
besoins de nos concitoyens et des
entreprises du pays
leur élaboration par ordonnance se
permettra en effet de gagner plusieurs
mois et peut-être n'en dans la
conjoncture actuelle c'est un temps
précieux retarder leur adoption serait
une erreur économique
tout autant que social et politique car
stimuler la construction et la
rénovation de logements et non seulement
un impératif humaines pour tous les
ménages qui ont du mal à se loger
mais c'est aussi un formidable moyen de
soutenir le secteur de la construction
est d'appuyer le tissu des tpe et des
pme du bâtiment qui rigole leur
territoire
d'ailleurs je relève un certain accord
sur le bien fondé des mesures envisagées
lors de l'examen en commission la
semaine dernière aucun des groupes
politiques n'a voté contre l'adoption du
texte
les réserves qui se sont exprimées sur
certains points aboutissants seulement
une abstention dont la tonalité m'a
semblé plutôt bienveillante
je me félicite de cette approche
constructive et pragmatique
elle constitue la reconnaissance que les
dispositions envisagées markten net
progrès vers plus de proximité plus de
simplicité et de réactivité de
l'administration nous avons là un bel
exemple du shop de simplification
appelée de ses voeux par le président de
la république qu'est ce que c'est sûr
que nous citoyens attendent ces dons
c'est dont notre économie a besoin
je terminerai mon intervention en
indiquant brièvement qu'elles sont de
mon point de vue les améliorations qui
me semble utile d'apporter à ce texte
à ce stade de son examen et quels sont
les principes fondamentaux sur la base
desquels je fonderai les avis que je
formulerai sur les différents
amendements au cours de la discussion
des articles
comme j'ai indiqué précédemment
plusieurs points qui me semblait devoir
être précisés l'ont été par des députés
au cours des débats à l'assemblée
nationale concernant la création d'un
régime de logements intermédiaires
ils ont clairement recentrer le
dispositif sur les zones caractérisées
par un déséquilibre important entre
l'offre et la demande de logements afin
d'éviter tout effet d'aubaine qu'ils ont
également précisé que le nouveau régime
concernera tant le parent locatif que
les logements destinés à l'accession
maîtrisé à la propriété ils ont fermé la
possibilité d'inscrire dans les
documents de planification des objectifs
relatifs à la construction de logements
intermédiaires aux communes faisant
l'objet l'objet d'un arrêté préfectoral
de carence au titre de l'article l le
319 du code de la construction et de
l'habitation
ils ont en dernier lieu imposé aux
filiales des organismes hlm qui
interviennent ou qui interviendront dans
le nouveau régime du logement de
respecter le principe d'étanchéité des
fonds relevant du logement social et ils
ont adopté en séance publique une
définition précise à cette notion
d'étanchéité toutes ces précisions sont
très utiles il me semble toutefois qu'il
faut rectifier la rédaction de l'alinéa
22 car elle interdit aux représentants
des collectivités territoriales ou de
leurs groupements de siéger à la fois
dans le conseil d'administration d'un
organisme hlm et dans celui de sa
filiale dédiée aux logements
intermédiaires
compte tenu des délais très courts de
transmission du texte après son adoption
en première lecture par l'assemblée
nationale
la modification nécessaire n'a pu être
apportée lors de l'examen en commission
cependant je vous proposerai tout à
l'heure une rédaction alternatives
concernant le point 5 de l'article
premier à savoir dans les conditions
dans lesquelles on peut apporter d'aidé
régulation des d'hérault
a sion aux règles des p lus afin de
densifier le bâti la commission des
affaires économiques a adopté jeudi
dernier
l'amendement que je lui ai proposé il
précise que les dérogations aux règles
des peines lui prévu pour densifier
seront une faculté une faculté ouverte
aux communes et non une obligation
précisions que vous aviez donné
oralement mais nous avons préféré
d'inscrire dans le pôle dans le texte de
loi également sur la question des
dérogations prévues au point cents je
trouve que la rédaction des alinéas 15
et 18 modifié et ça s'explique notamment
par les députés n'est pas d'une grande
clarté s excuser cet effet misme je vous
présenterai dont un amendement pour
rendre ces dispositions plus aisément
compréhensible et intelligible enfin les
débats à l'assemblée nationale et devant
la commission des affaires économiques
du sénat ont montré sinon une inquiétude
du moins une certaine vigilance quant à
la nécessité d'opérer un arbitrage enfin
sur la question des obligations en
matière d'aires de stationnement que
l'épée l'ue doivent encourager la
création de logements et le recours au
transport collectif plutôt que de
gaspiller
il est évident pardon que l'épée l'ue
doivent encourager la création de
logements et le recours au transport
collectif plutôt que de gaspiller le
foncier disponible pour y réaliser des
aires de stationnement individuel ceci
étant il faut veiller à trouver un
équilibre entre cet objectif et celui de
fournir aux habitants des disponibilités
suffisantes en matière d'aires de
stationnement car un déficit dans
l'offre de parking serait vraiment de
nature à compliquer la vie quotidienne
de nos concitoyens
s'ils n'en demande pas tant j'ai entendu
mes collègues y compris ceux de
l'opposition qui ont tous soulevé qui
ont soulevé ce point dans les débats en
commission
je vous proposerai donc qu'un amendement
en eau a dû points 5 afin de préciser
les conditions de dérogation obligations
en matière d'aires de stationnement
devant tenir compte de la qualité de la
desserte en transports collectifs ont de
la densité urbaine
cela va sans dire mais cela va mieux en
le précisant pour le reste il me semble
indispensable de maintenir sa cohérence
et son unité au texte présenté par le
gouvernement
l'objectif est de faire avancer un
certain nombre de sujets clairement
identifiés circonscrit et urgents pas
d'anticiper sur la loi du faux deux ânes
ouvrant le débat sur des questions
d'urbanisme à la fois fondamentales
complexes et potentiellement
déstabilisantes
du point de vue de la sécurité juridique
et des collectivités en cabane en
particulier vous le savez un texte sur
l'urbanisme est toujours propice au
dépôt et à discussion d'un grand nombre
d'amendements qui répondent à des
préoccupations louable et qui parfois
même apporte des réponses juridiques
pertinentes à telle ou telle situation
précise mais qui peuvent aussi aboutir à
modifier le code d'urbanisme par petites
touches et sans cohérence la loi duflot
2 et je n'en doute pas madame la
ministre permettra à l'automne de
rependre les questions soulevées par les
divers amendements portant articles
additionnels et de les traiter de façon
plus satisfaisante dans le cadre d'une
réforme globale
c'est pourquoi je proposerai
systématiquement le retrait pour six
amendements
au final je vous rappelle je vous
appelle
chers collègues et cela ne vous
surprendra pas à voter ce projet de loi
d'habilitation je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue dans la
discussion générale la parole et à
monsieur rené vandierendonck rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des lois
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
mes chers collègues je vois devant moi
mon collègue daniel dubois et et ses
murs ses murs résonnent encore des deux
interventions successives qu'il a
réalisé première c'était encore benoist
apparu qui était ministre et il posait
déjà la question
rendons lui hommage sur l'intériorité de
ce problème de ces recours abusifs et
est dilatoire et je j'entends encore
benoist apparu dire qu'à cela ne tienne
un décret en conseil d'état est imminent
je revois avec la ténacité la pugnacité
qu'on lui connaît le même
sénateur reposer la question alors que
sur un texte qui portait à l'époque sur
la majoration des droits à construire
ici même madame la ministre avait promis
de rechercher efficacement des solutions
à un problème lancinant lancinant qui
est aujourd'hui en france à l'origine de
hal et 25000 logements construits en
moins par an mes chers collègues 5000 à
marseille qui vise justement à
s'attaquer à ce problème du recours
dilatoire abusif abusif dilatoires et
donc je vous donne acte
madame la ministre d'avoir choisi la
meilleure des méthodes qui soit en
recourant à ce groupe de travail présidé
il est vrai par un juriste hors pair
ancien président de la section du
contentieux du conseil d'état
daniel laboute houle accompagnée d'un
groupe de travail constitué vraiment de
tous les professionnels concernés par
ces problèmes
eh bien il il ressort et la commission
des lois a apprécié et la méthode et les
propositions il ressort de vos
propositions
des mesures qui s'inscrivent en totale
cohérence d'abord avec l'action que vous
menez depuis l'été 2012 pour lever les
freins à la construction dans notre pays
et pour encourager la production de
logements donc je voulais dire sans
ambiguïté un que les mesures qui ont été
préconisées par le groupe de travail et
si j'ai bien compris que vous comptez
reprendre à l'exception mais vous nous
en direz peut-être plus tout à l'heure
si ce n'est déjà fait à l'exception
d'une qui semblent manifester chez vous
quelques réticences qui est
l'action enfin les restrictions à
l'action en démolition
toujours est il que vous avez annoncé
clairement j'ai suivi un peu les travaux
à l'assemblée nationale aussi vous avez
annoncé clairement votre intention par
le biais de la procédure des ordonnances
de vous inspirer des principales
dispositions de ce groupe de travail
je vais donc les rappeler parce que les
ont tous reçu un avis plus que favorable
de la commission des lois
la première recommandation est vise à
clarifier les règles de l'intérêt pour
agir
c'est d'ailleurs parce que c'est peu sus
à d'ailleurs utile de rappeler qu'avant
même que le groupe de travail la bédoule
se réunissent il y avait déjà dans le
code de l'urbanisme des restrictions
notamment sur la qualité pour agir des
associations qui se constitueraient
spécifiquement pour faire leurs courses
postérieurement à l'affichage en mairie
mais là il s'agit d'aller plus loin
c'est à dire de permettre aux juges sur
le fondement d'un tex l'ordonance dont
il s'agit de veiller à un bon équilibre
entre le droit au recours et le droit à
construire et pour cela de resserrer si
j'ose dire l'intérêt à agir au cas
d'atteintes directes aux conditions
d'occupation d'utilisation ou de
jouissance du bien posséder ou occupés
ça me paraît contribuer à la recherche
de la solution
la seconde recommandation vise à ce
qu'on appelle enfin le groupe de travail
appelle la cristallisation des moyens à
savoir que dans la maîtrise qui lui si
tu reviens du calendrier de la procédure
contentieuse le juge pourrait dire à un
certain moment
bon allez l'exception bien sûr des
moyens d'ordre public
je n'admettrai plus c'est le juge qui
parle dans cet exemple je n'admettrai
plus que de nouveaux moyens soit léguée
pour la première fois maintenant à
partir de cette date
avantage de cette procédure c'est
qu'effectivement ça compliqué donc ça
annihile les faits dilatoire là à
d'une distillation bien comprise des
moyens et donc je trouve que on aurait
tort de ne pas essayer
troisième piste institué un mécanisme de
régularisation si j'ose dire en cours
d'instance à l'initiative du juge ça
c'est aussi novateur ce que bon les
juristes qui ont à peu près mon nageurs
ont été éduqués dans la logique le droit
applicable se cristallisent le jour de
l'arc est là on permettrait pour par
exemple des vices de forme et des vices
de procédure le juge les constatant
pourrait dire écoutez il ya une
annulation plus que probable sauf si
dans un délai de temps un permis
modificatif ne vient pas en quelque
sorte régulariser c'est à dire faire
disparaître la colle d'illégalité c'est
extrêmement constructif et novateur
quatrième moyens mis en oeuvre dans
cette logique de donner une plus grande
efficacité
et de lutter contre les recours abusifs
c'est le dispositif qui permet aux
défendeurs c'est à dire à la victime du
recours abusif de présenter devant le
juge administratif le juge de
l'annulation le juge de l'excès de
pouvoir comme on dit de présenter devant
lui immédiatement des demandes en
indemnité ça croyez moi c'est l'entrée
de la dissuasion nucléaire dans le
contentieux de la rrq puisque
effectivement auch et bien vous me direz
ma collègue annick lepetit s'est attaché
à sa l'international dit on peut relever
le plafond 3000 euros pourquoi on met
pas dix mille non il vaut mieux suivre
cette voie là parce que que vous le
mettiez à 3000 ou à 10000 de toute façon
c'est l'état qui encaisse à l'arrivée 1
tandis que là c'est effectivement c'est
effectivement la victime c'est à dire
le promoteur qui a pas pu construire et
qui s'est exposé à des agios bancaires
ou que sais-je encore qui est
bénéficiaire de cette mesure
donc je nous l'avons prouvé à la
commission des lois
extrêmement intéressante et méritant
d'être expérimenté la commission des
lois a toutefois fait observer mais ça
n'avait pas échappé à votre sagacité
madame la ministre que cette action dans
lordonnance il faudrait faire en sorte
qu elles n'interdisent pas autrement
dans un problème constitutionnel de
partage de désordre juridictionnel
administratif et judiciaire
quel n'interdisent pas éventuellement à
la victime une action devant le juge
civil à en posteriori si elle choisit
après tout cette voie contentieuse là
une autre recommandation ça c'est aussi
extrêmement efficace l'errance honneur
moi je les appelle comme ça parce que
vous préférez voyez les chats l'errance
honneur à tous ceux qui font tous ceux
qui font profession donc de faire des
recours et puis après d'aller voir le
celui qui a donné le permis on dit donc
ça peut s'arranger a eu à les cent mille
euros de 100000 euros on en parle plus
ce que j'appelle les rançonneurs serait
quand même lourdement dissuader de
persister dans ses méthodes
est ce pas toujours des margoulins les
condamnations pour escroquerie qu'il
commence à tomber montre qu'il s'agit
parfois de promoteurs ayant parfaitement
pignon sur rue
donc l'avantagent de cette formule c'est
un enregistrement devant
l'administration fiscale qui parce
qu'après tout une transaction de en
désistement elle n'est pas condamnable
en soi ce qui est condamnable c'est
quand elle aboutit à ce que j'appelle la
la demande de rançon là le fait qu'ils
auraient une publicité une obligation
surtout de l'enregistrement devant
l'administration fiscale suppose que ces
impôts indirects et à mon avis une très
bonne chose donc on a compris
madame la ministre que vous étiez pas
spécialement intéressé par la 6e mesure
qui vise à recentrer l'action de
démolition sur son objet premier en
clair à limiter les cas où la démolition
serait juridiquement possible afin de
freiner l'effet dissuasif dans
l'engagement des acquis après tout sont
exécutoires et enfin la dernière
préconisations des du groupe de travail
et la halle et novatrice a pour eux les
avocats dans la salle et les magistrats
vous apprécierez elle vise à permettre
une voie contentieuse explicite en
premier et dernier ressort un recours en
annulation qui serait directement porté
devant la cour administrative d'appel en
premier et dernier ressort qui serait
comme il s'agit d'une procédure
exorbitante du droit commun qui est
quand même le double degré de
juridiction
monsieur l'abbé tools la limite avec un
critères cumulatifs qui serait que la
délivrance de l'acte sur le territoire
de la commune interviennent dans là où
il ya une urgence sociale particulière 1
et notamment dans la taxe annuelle sur
les logements vacants applicables et la
deuxième chose c'est que l'acte devrait
porter sur des constructions d'une
certaine importance et il aimait
l'hypothèse de 15 100 m² de shon minimum
donc vous dire que la commission des
lois
d'autant plus qu'entre temps les risques
qui pesait sur la constitutionnalité de
la nécessité par ordonnance de revenir
sur deux dispositions du code de
l'expropriation ont disparu et un e
donc je ne vais pas vous en parler mais
en plus qu'à naturellement il avait eu
aussi un avis favorable de la commission
des lois la commission des lois a salué
le caractère exemplaire novateur la
méthode que vous avez choisi le délai
dans lequel vous avez inscrit votre
action et est donc je vais je vais vous
le dire
et comme je voudrais conclure en vous
priant de d'excusés le manque d'élégance
démocratique dont je fais part mais
j'aurais dû être là pendant bien sûr
votre discours mais votre cabinet
m'avait fort gentiment dispensés dans la
mesure où on à 850 amendements en cours
d'analysé à la commission des lois voilà
je vous remercie de votre attente
merci mon cher collègue dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est un
malade mirail cherche pour 8 minutes
vous avez la parole mais chaque oeil
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je veux
d'abord remercier monsieur le rapporteur
pour la qualité de ses présentations
lors de nos séances en commission et
pour ces amendements de précision
souvent utile suite aux déclarations du
président de la république le 21 mars
dernier vous nous présenter madame la
ministre ce projet de loi portant
habilitation du gouvernement à légiférer
par voie d'ordonnancé pour accélérer les
projets de construction vous le savez
nous sommes en principe opposer à ce
type de dispositif qui sous couvert
d'urgence prive le parlement de ses
prérogatives en matière législative nous
avons décrié ensemble ces méthodes
récurrentes sous l'ère sarkozy
nous aurions pu légitimement espérer en
ce domaine aussi le changement
d'autre part cette démarche s'inscrit
malheureusement dans une atmosphère
politique où les droits du parlement
sont régulièrement foulé aux pieds
je citerai à titre d'exemple le recours
au vote bloqué sur la niche ou encore
les conditions ça vient d'être appelé
d'examen de l'acte iii de la
décentralisation
sans parler de la proposition de loi de
mon groupe sur la mini psy social au jet
d'une fin de non recevoir du
gouvernement le parlement n'est pas une
chambre d'enregistrement
en outre cette loi ouvre la voie à la
réforme annoncée du logement comme vous
nous l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé en lien
avec l'acte iii de la décentralisation
elle ne peut donc s'appréhender en
dehors de ce contexte très spécifique
sur le fond le constat de la crise du
logement est partagé par tous les bons
ici comme aussi l'urgence d'y remédier
nous connaissons madame la ministre
votre implication la matière et ce en
dépit des fourches caudines de bercy
liés aux impératifs d'austérité nous
avons lu attentivement l'étude d'impact
de ce projet de loi la volonté de
transformer des bureaux en logements par
exemple où la fin de la garantie
intrinsèque pour les ventres en état de
futur achèvement sont de bonnes mesures
pourtant certains autres et ce malgré
les objectifs affichés visant la
densification et la lutte contre
l'étalement urbain
objectif que nous partageons pleinement
nous voyons la marque de l'art des
réglementations en matière d'urbanisme
soyons clairs nous ne pensons pas que la
complexité et le nombre des normes de
l'urbanisme et il faudrait y regarder de
plus près en effet soit la cause
principale de la crise du logement
en effet ce sont bien les politiques de
marchandisation adossé à une
débudgétisation de la politique du
logement politique menée depuis dix ans
par la droite qui ont conduit à cette
crise ouvrant la voie de la spéculation
immobilière et foncière
pour cette raison et vous le savez nous
avons fait des propositions précises
notamment en matière de foncier
nous considérons qu'il s'agit là du
principal levier à débloquer pour
relancer la construction
nous pouvons à ce titre au delà des
objectifs affichés par le présent texte
nous interroger sur la volonté de
débloquer de nouveaux droits à
construire dérogatoire pour surélever
les immeubles en fête
une telle disposition risque risque de
provoquer un renchérissement des prix
des terrains contradictoire avec les
objectifs affichés de lutte contre la
spéculation immobilière
par ailleurs nous estimons que la voie
de la multiplication des dérogations op
et lui n'est pas un bon signe envoyé aux
collectivités à leurs habitants même si
ces dérogations sont facultatives
monsieur le rapporteur nous l'a bien
souligné
en effet le pl lui constitue la pierre
angulaire d'une politique d'un projet
politique locale élaboré avec la
population les temps de procédure
d'élaboration comme de modifications
sont longs mais ce temps démocratique
est nécessaire
ainsi si nous jugeons que les règles
actuelles définie dans le code de
l'urbanisme en matière de paix
lui ne répondent pas aux enjeux de
densification mixité de lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols
ce sont ces règles qu'il faut changer et
non à notre avis permettre le recours à
des dérogations par ailleurs source sans
doute de nouveaux contentieux pour les
collectivités nous devrons y revenir au
travers sans doute de cette la prochaine
loi sur le logement que vous nous
annoncez à ce titre nous sommes
dubitatifs sur la mesure qui veut qu'il
puisse être porté atteinte à l'économie
générale d'un pda d'un pea d'aidé au
travers la nouvelle procédure dite
procédure intégré pour le logement
au surplus multiplié les dérogations à
la règle d'urbanisme établi localement
et démocratiquement risque de porter
atteinte à la cohérence globale des
politiques d'aménagement de la même
manière si nous voulons limiter ce qui
est juste le nombre de stationnements
il faut il faut qu'il existe des
alternatives crédibles et accessible en
termes de transports en commun et c'est
bien l'objet d'un amendement que vous
nous avez proposé monsieur le rapporteur
ce matin mais nous regrettons que notre
peau propositions sur le passe navigo
est été retoqué alors qu en augmentant
la recette du versement transport
elle allait bien dans le sens d'une
amélioration du réseau donc une
amélioration de la qualité des
transports en commun en outre même si
cela n'est pas votre attention madame la
ministre
cette démarche laisse entendre en
filigrane que la crise du logement
actuel serait imputable aux élus locaux
qui ne ferait pas le nécessaire au
travers leurs documents d'urbanisme pour
favoriser la construction
c'est parfois vrai mais il semble que
l'essentiel soit à rechercher ailleurs
à notre avis la cherté du foncier et la
faiblesse des aides publiques
un mot tout de même sur cette question
importante des recours abusifs dont nous
venons de parler à restants nous
partageons la volonté de limiter ces
recours par une réduction des délais
ou par l'affirmation de sanctions
dissuasives comme le texte prévoit
encore faut-il que les tribunaux
puissent répondre en termes de moyens
humains à cette demande nous vous
alertons aussi sur le fait que 2 que de
par cette habilitation la limitation des
recours passe aussi par une diminution
d'accès à la justice en limitant
l'intérêt agir vous allez peut-être nous
en dire plus tout à l'heure puisque
c'est une question que l'on s'est posé
ce matin pour finir sur les mesures
contenues par ce projet de loi nous
sommes également circonspect sur la
place tenue par le logement
intermédiaire au regard de l'ampleur non
seulement de la crise du logement mais
également de la crise sociale
il nous semble en effet que l'urgence et
le logement social puisque vous l'avez
rappelé ce sont 60 % de la population
qui peuvent y prétendre
1 million 700 mille demandes qui restent
à satisfaire actes et d'un écart de prix
entre le logement social et le logement
dit de marché ne devrait pas nous
conduire à vouloir remplir le creux
confortant par là même ses prix élevés
mais bien réfléchir à des mécanismes
permettant de ramener les prix de marché
à des niveaux permettant réellement à
nos concitoyens d'accéder au logement
par le blocage des loyers bien sûr mais
également par un encadrement du foncier
à ce titre nous aimerions savoir madame
la ministre ou en est donc le rapport
que nous avons fait adopter si même
permettant la mise en oeuvre d'un
mécanisme visant à encadrer justement
les prix du foncier par ailleurs délier
la propriété de l'usufruit est une idée
que nous avons porté au travers notre
projet de proposition de loi sur
l'agencé nationale foncière pour le
logement
cependant nous jugeons cette
dissociation intéressante et forte utile
non pour bénéficier aux investisseurs
bénéficiant d'ores et déjà du dispositif
fiscal qui porte votre nom mais bien aux
organismes hlm pour construire des
logements sociaux
adossé à une tva à 5% voilà une mesure
qui pourrait relancer utilement l'effort
de construction
en outre la possibilité laissée aux
offices de faire des filiales ne risque
t'elle page pour la question de les
détourner de leur coeur de missions
relevant de l'intérêt général nous
seront également très attentifs à ce que
les logements dits intermédiaires ne
soit pas décomptés dans les cent
cinquante mille logements sociaux à
construire au final d'accord ce projet
de loi appelle une nouvelle fois la
responsabilité la charge des
collectivités au travers de la garantie
financière apportée aux opérations
d'aménagement ou encore la mise en place
du géoportail mais vous nous avez
rassuré c'est l'état qui va payer
ma question est très simple où se situe
la garantie de l'état bâtisseur qui
dispose je vous le rappelle d'une
responsabilité première en matière de
logement parce que nous prenons très au
sérieux l'ensemble de ces questions que
nous souhaitons le respect des
compétences des collectivités
territoriales que nous voulons sortir le
logement des considérations marchandes
que nous nous abstiendrons sur ce texte
comme un signal au gouvernement sur le
niveau d'exigence que nous portons et
sur le respect qui doit être celui du
travail parlementaire
je vous remercie merci mes chers
collègues dans la discussion générale la
parole et à monsieur daniel dubois pour
dix minutes
sur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues je suis très
heureux d'être là aujourd'hui finalement
puisque deux fois gérer les rapporteurs
ont signifié que j'étais beaucoup
intervenu sur les recours donc alors
madame la ministre
le logement on le sait représente avec
la santé et l'emploi
une des principales priorités des
français
il est d'ailleurs en tête de leurs
attentes pour les prochaines échéances
municipales
il apparaît également comme le premier
poste de dépenses des ménages et ce
particulièrement pour les familles les
plus modestes et pour les classes
moyennes
l'amélioration de la qualité des
logements la construction de nouveaux
bâtiments doivent donc constituer un
engagement fort de tous les acteurs
publics et bien entendu du gouvernement
nous sommes prêts madame la ministre à
vous soutenir dans cette tâche difficile
comme nous l'avions déjà dit lors du
premier projet de loi que vous aviez
défendu à l'automne dernier néanmoins
néanmoins même la ministre
le constat est aussi sévère parce que
force est de constater en effet que les
résultats des douze derniers mois ne
sont pas très rassurants et pour tout
dire sont plutôt alarmants
pardonnez-moi par avance pour la série
de chiffres mais ils sont importants au
cours du premier trimestre 2013
premier trimestre 2013 seulement 84
mille logements ont été mis en chantier
sur l'ensemble du territoire français
soit une baisse de 11 2% par rapport au
premier trimestre de 2012
sur les douze mois d'avril 2012 à mars
2013 seulement 315 mille logements ont
été mis en chantier soit respectivement
une baisse d'environ 18% par rapport à
l'année précédente où sont
où sont les cinq cent mille logements
promis dont les cent cinquante mille
logements locatifs ces tristes résultats
sont extrêmement dommageable pour les
français et dommageables pour les
entreprises du bâtiment
car au delà des questions de logement
c'est bien l'emploi qui est en jeu lui
dei et jean loup après jean louis borloo
ne cesse d'interpeller votre
gouvernement sur ce secteur et nous
avons l'impression que vous êtes sourd à
nos appels
je pense par exemple à la question de la
tva dans le bâtiment et en particulier
pour la construction de logements
sociaux
une fois de plus nous vous demandons de
revenir sur cette hausse dont les seuls
effets sont de pénaliser encore les plus
fragiles et de détruire des emplois non
délocalisables
il y a donc urgence à agir dans ce
secteur et c'est bien le constat que
nous partageons le président de la
république a défini le 21 mars dernier
un plan logement en vain mesures pour le
secteur du bâtiment et notamment le
désormais fameux choc de simplification
des normes qui figure dans le texte qui
nous est soumis aujourd'hui alors même
la ministre
s'il y a des convergences sur l'analyse
les moyens d'y arriver peuvent nous
diviser
d'abord sur la forme et sur le recours
aux ordonnances
je vous le dis avec force les centristes
n'accepte pas le recours aux ordonnances
pour légiférer c'est un dessaisissement
complet de notre rôle de législateur et
c'est pardonnez moi l'expression com de
com de demander à une demande de voter
pour noël plus sérieusement lui
sérieusement sur la durée plus
sérieusement mes chers collègues sur la
durée de l'habilitation et sur son champ
je formulerai quelques remarques pour
essayer soit de comprendre
soin de vous interroger madame la
ministre sur la durée ou plutôt sur les
durées je ne comprends pas pourquoi
elles sont si longues
nous souhaitons tout d'abord les
homogénéiser pour l'ensemble des huit
points de l'article 1er il n'y a aucune
région que certaines priorités soit ici
plus difficile à écrire que d'autres en
outre nous vous proposerons également un
amendement visant à réduire tous les
délais de publication d'un tiers ce qui
revient à les diminuer d'un ou deux mois
le président de la république a fait ces
annonces il ya maintenant deux mois et
ce projet de loi a été adopté en conseil
des ministres il y à un mois
nous supposons donc que vos services ont
déjà travaillé et que ce
raccourcissement ne les pénalisera pas
et au moins sera un effet réel de
booster le relais pour la construction
et l'activité
d'autant plus et j'insiste il y a
urgence on ne peut pas attendre huit
mois de publication et cinq de plus
avant la présentation des textes devant
le parlement sur cet aspect je retiens
madame la ministre votre volonté de
venir présenter les ordonnances devant
notre commission avant publication
c'est une démarche positive à saluer
nous serons bien sûr attentif de rêve à
ce qu'elle se réalise sur le fond
maintenant des huit points contenu à
l'article 1er une grande partie nous
satisfait et répond à l'urgence de la
situation le raccourcissement des délais
de délivrance des permis de construire
par la mise en place d'une procédure
intégré pour le logement devrait
faciliter la réalisation d'opérations
d'aménagement de même nous soutenons
aussi la réduction du délai des recours
contentieux et la lutte contre les
recours abusifs
je salue aussi l'amendement de précision
que notre rapporteur a fait adopter au
cinquième mans sur les dérogations
prévues pour l'augmentation de la
densification la clarification était
nécessaire pour les mères qui voyait
dans la réflexion précédente une
simplification qui se mettait en place
sans leur contrôle et leur accord en
revanche madame la ministre des doux
subsistent en particulier sur deux
points sur lesquels j'ai déposé des
amendements sur le développement du
logement intermédiaire à prix maîtrisés
la création d'un bail de longue durée
dédiée à la production de ce type de
logement et sur la possibilité pour les
organismes de logement social de créer
des filiales dédiées à la production et
à la gestion de logements intermédiaires
nous sommes convaincus qu'un projet de
loi dédiée doit être déposée cela
nécessite des débats importants et pas
seulement une ordonnance alors même
qu'un projet de loi importants nous est
soumis à l'automne il sera plus adapté
pour en débattre sereinement
l'urgence est d'autant moins grande que
vous fixé à 8 mois le délai pour
bobillier cette ordonnance
donc soit c'est urgent soit on a un vrai
débat et nous vous proposerons un
amendement permettant de sortir de cette
mesure du champ des ordonnances de la
même manière
l'augmentation du taux maximal de
garantie d'emprunt des collectivités
locales nous semble problématique
vous êtes madame la ministre sans doute
trop optimiste quant à ses effets sur la
construction et j'estime que cette
mesure peut faire peser un risque
financier important pour les
collectivités
hmm hmm et vous l'avez dit clairement si
ce n'est qu'une possibilité qui leur est
offert un où les budgets sont serrés à
un moment où l'état diminue ses
dotations
cela me paraît présenter un vrai risque
juste un mot pour dire que l'on ne
pourra pas continuer à demander encore
et toujours plus aux collectivités et
aux élus tout en les étranglant
financièrement leur bonne volonté ne
suffit plus enfin une interrogation a
surgi à l'assemblée nationale sur la
cohérence de la 8ème mesure sur
l'augmentation de la trésorerie des
entreprises du bâtiment avec un article
du projet de loi relatif à la
consommation l'article 61 je crois qui
vise quant à lui à réduire les délais de
paiement interentreprises de 60 à 45
jours
donc là d'un côté on cherche à améliorer
la situation des entreprises de la
construction et du bâtiment dans leurs
relations avec leurs clients et d'un
autre côté on les pénalise
ce qu'elles vont gagner en trésorerie
d'un côté ne risque-t-elle pas de le
perdre de l'autre puisque on réduit les
délais à 45 jours d'un côté pouvez-vous
nous rassure et madame la ministre sur
la volonté réelle du gouvernement
en conclusion madame la mini c'est pour
toutes ces raisons les sénateurs du
groupe d uc continuent à s'interroger et
je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur jacques mézard pour 8 minutes
c'est très sûr qu'on la descente on en a
peur
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
madame la ministre comment vous gâcher
mon plaisir de vous voir ici dans cette
haute assemblée
présenter personnellement ce projet de
loi destiné à voir habilité le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnances
pour accélérer les projets de
construction je ne doute pas que vous le
faites au nom de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'état passant ainsi outre aux
réticences qui pourrait légitimement
vous éloigner du choix de cette voie
procédurale qui tout à la fois abouti à
évincer en partie le parlement de ses
prérogatives habituel mais à lutter
efficacement contre tous ceux qui par
visées spéculatives ou pour défendre des
intérêts particuliers plus ou moins
déguisée par de bons principes frêne ou
empêche tout simplement la construction
l'euro perdait ce dans sa grande
majorité votera ce projet de loi malgré
ses réticences quant à l'utilisation de
la procédure des ordonnances à laquelle
comme vous je crois nous considérons
qu'il ne doit être recourue
qu'exceptionnellement en l'occurrence
relancer aussi on fait le compte mon
cher collègue un des recours aux
ordonnances chaque gouvernement a sa
dose
en l'occurrence relancer la construction
loger chacune de nos familles dans un
logement décent à un coût accessible
c'est là une vraie priorité nationale
une priorité qui au delà de l'aspect
purement social ne peut avoir que des
impacts positifs et immédiat pour
l'économie du pays et pour l'emploi
madame la ministre
la société change les aspirations de nos
concitoyens aussi les orientations des
pouvoirs publics de la même façon vérité
d'un jour n'est plus forcément celle du
lendemain
il en est ainsi dans le secteur
important de l'urbanisme et du logement
j'ai encore en mémoire les discours et
les actions de nombre d'associations et
d'élus contre la densification contre la
construction hauteur contre les tours
j'ai en mémoire les occases de certains
abf dans les zones dans les mpr voulant
figé pour l'éternité
les constructions du passé de toute
nature or madame la ministre l'homme
c'est la vie la vie c'est le mouvement
les civilisations passent et trépassent
il en est de même des espèces dans ses
propos liminaires je me dois d'attirer
votre attention sur l'impérieuse
nécessité de ne pas oublier y compris à
l'occasion de ce texte que vous êtes en
charge de l'égalité territoriale avec
pour corollaire l'aménagement du
territoire et ce n'est pas
contradictoire avec les questions de
densification et jeudi une nouvelle fois
attention aux critères d'ailleurs
contestable des zones tendues et
détendue il n'est pas raisonnable de
bloquer de fait la construction dans les
zones détendues pour concentrer tous les
moyens dans les zones dites tendues
abandon et déserts sont des mots que
nous entendons que nous subissons trop
dans plusieurs départements
profitons davantage des grands espaces
là où il y en a
chacun reconnaîtra qu'il y a urgence à
agir
l'urgence économique bien sûr par
rapport aux problèmes du secteur de la
construction de son ralentissement
urgence sociale ensuite car la
suppression d'emplois s'ajoutent plus de
trois millions et demi de français
mal-logés urgences environnementales
enfin avec là aussi presque 4 millions
de ménages vivant en situation de
précarité énergétique et nous sommes
d'accord sur le fait qu' un grand
chantier à mener prioritaires important
urgent et celui des économies d'énergie
ce qui est fondamental en matière
d'habitat de logements c'est d'autant
plus alarmant que les besoins de demain
seront accrues du fait de la croissance
démographique et de nouveaux
comportements
dès son entrée en fonction le
gouvernement a montré sa volonté
d'apporter rapidement des réponses et
nous tenons et ce n'est pas toujours le
cas loin de là a salué cette action
mobilisation du foncier de l'état
renforcement de la loi sru en forme en
faveur du logement social relèvement du
plafond du livret a
taxation de la rétention foncière ou
encore l'incitation à l'investissement
locatif avec cette fois de réelles
contreparties sociales tout cela pour
nous va dans le bon sens mais nous
l'avions dit lors des précédents débats
des réflexions et des actions restent à
mener notamment sur la simplification
des règles d'urbanisme pour atteindre
l'objectif ambitieux mais nécessaire de
500 mille logements par an entre aix et
d'application du principe de précaution
et excès de bureaucratie le terrain à
bâtir finit en effet par devenir
inconstructibles et ce projet de loi
d'habilitation vise à lever rapidement
certains freins nous sommes évidemment
favorables à une procédure simplifiée
par pour le logement
en effet la lourdeur la complexité des
procédures induisent non seulement des
délais et des coûts exorbitants mais
conduit souvent à une forme
d'autocensure des acteurs locaux quand
il s'agit de réviser les documents
d'urbanisme
il est proposé d'augmenter à 100 % le
niveau de la garantie des collectivités
locales pour les apps opérations
d'aménagement d'intérêt général les
banques sont aujourd'hui de plus en plus
exigeante et nous avons bien compris
tout ce qu'il s'agissait seulement
d'ouvrir une faculté supplémentaire et
non d'imposer une obligation
collectivité mais cela me donne une
occasion nous interpeller sur leur
situation financière fragile
on peut pas leur demander à ces
collectivités toujours plus et geler
voire réduire leur marge de manoeuvre
autre objectif essentiel jeudi la
densification
aujourd'hui les choeurs de certaines
villes sont en voie de nécrose
nous devons densifier de manière utile
et intelligente y compris dans les zones
rurales vers les bourses entre la les
questions de transport est question de
charges de centralité construire sur les
dents creuses et sur les toits ne doit
pas être iconoclaste
le plus difficile sera sans doute de
faire passer le message à
l'administration et aux architectes des
bâtiments de france
il est proposé d'ouvrir des dérogations
aux règles relatives au gabarit et à la
densité des constructions ainsi qu aux
obligations de création d'aires de
stationnement non pas de manière
uniforme et automatique sur tout le
territoire mais de les réserver aux
zones tendues la définition de ces zones
je le redis retenu par l'assemblée
nationale et celle utilisée pour la taxe
sur les logements vacants
je comprends l'intérêt de retenir une
référence commune plus récente que celle
de la loi dite molle que j'ai moi même
souvent critiqué ici car mal adapté
parfois contre productive et sans
dimension prospective
mais je m'interroge sur le bien fondé du
seuil de 50 mille habitants dans
certains départements il ya des zones
moins peuplées qui n'en sont pas moins
des zones tendues
cette réflexion aussi vaut aussi pour le
logement intermédiaire autre point de ce
projet de loi auquel nous sommes très
favorables
la sortie de celle m est devenu
difficile pour de nombreux ménages et ce
n'est pas à coups de surloyer ou de
contraintes que l'on rétablit le
parcours résidentiel
il nous faut des logements à prix
raisonnable en faisant appel à l'épargné
institutionnelle mais il faut veiller à
ce que ça ne fasse pas aux dépens du
logement social et à ne pas détourner
nos bailleurs sociaux de leur mission
première
nous sommes d'accord d'ailleurs et que
les amendements adoptés par l'assemblée
nationale
enfin madame la ministre nous sommes
très favorables au volet qui concerne la
réduction des délais de traitement du
contentieux en matière d'urbanisme et la
lutte contre les recours abusifs je
viens tous les recours abusifs et pas
simplement masquer que faut à mon sens
définir l'intérêt à agir nous en
reparlerons et entre le recours qui
relève du droit dont dispose chaque
citoyen de contester devant le juge
une décision lui faisant grief est celui
que l'on pourrait qualifier de mafieux
il y a aussi le recours émanant de
voisin irascible ou celui formé des
associations protège protégeant fait des
intérêts très particuliers au mépris de
l'intérêt général
quels rapports l'abbé tout qui propose
de faire référence aux conditions
d'occupation d'utilisation de jouissance
du bien
je crois que le gouvernement devra nous
indiquer les pistes qu'il entend retenir
quoi qu'il en soit il faut que ces
recours soient lourdement sanctionnés
lorsqu'ils sont abusifs et valable amis
je conclurai là dessus si vous voulez
réellement accélérer la procédure
découlant de tous ses recours de toutes
ces normes aussi il faut bien le dire
c'est indispensable mais il faudra agir
sur la procédure administrative ya les
pistes et à ce moment là il faut
s'intéresser aux moyens des juridictions
administratives à la procédure
administrative et ça c'est quelque chose
qui urgent parce que nous connaissons
tous les dossiers dans ce pays qui sont
aujourd'hui bloqués par la
multiplication de ces recours de ces
normes par le premier degré l'appel le
conseil d'état et juridiction
administrative c'est devenu un vrai
problème auquel il faut que nous nous
attaquions voilà très simplement ce que
je voulais vous dire en concluant en
vous rappelant que nous voterons très
majoritairement ce texte
en dépit évidemment du problème de
principe qu'il posait qu'il pose mais
qui toujours celui du recours aux
ordonnances merci merci mon cher
collègue la discussion générale apparent
le thème monsieur joël labbé pour sept
minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
c'est le président de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
construire plus tout en construisant
mieux
tel doit être notre objectif je crois
vous citez la madame la ministre pour
répondre à l'urgence de la crise du
logement
je voudrais dire aussi deux mots de la
question des ordonnances j'étais
intervenu en commission d'autres jours
madame la ministre vous m'avez qu'on
veut vous m'avez convaincu parce que les
ordonnances bien sûr et sur une ou
l'autre il pourrait y avoir à discuter
mais globalement les ordinands des
ordonnances doivent répondre à une
urgence d'une nécessité de réactivité
on nous sommes dans cette situation une
situation de crise une crise qui n'en
finit pas et sans doute si nous si nous
ne changeons pas de logique qui n'en
finira pas quand on parle logement il
importe de rappeler les fondamentaux
le logement c'est un bien premier un
bien nécessaire avoir un logement est un
droit constitutionnel
c'est une priorité pour les individus et
les familles c'est aussi une priorité
nationale et madame la ministre vous
nous le démontrer en permanence avec
cette pêche que vous avez nous avons
besoin d'avoir des ministres qui ont la
pêche avocate infinie infatigable comme
vous l'avez du tout à l'heure pour la
cause du logement
hélas ce ne sont pas que des mots avoir
un logement décent tient bien du droite
à vivre dans la dignité sans logement
pas de vie privée
pas de vie familiale la plupart du temps
pas de travail pas d'intégration pas de
vie sociale pas dit du tout les
difficultés économiques et sociales
contribuent aujourd'hui à l'aggravement
de la précarité
nombre de nos concitoyens de tous âges
qu'ils soient jeunes qu'ils soient des
familles entières qu'ils soient des
personnes âgées sont concernés par cette
crise du logement
alors oui la situation actuelle justifie
un recours d'urgence
en effet chaque semaine chaque mois de
gagner du fait de l'application de ces
ordonnances sera autant de temps
et de sérénité de gagner pour les
personnes et les familles concernées
c'est aussi autant de temps de gagné
pour le secteur du bâtiment qui a vu en
un an une baisse de l'ordre de 18% des
mises en chantier ce qui a entraîné des
pertes d'emploi chiffré à l'ordre de
tresses 1800 2012 sans même compter les
postes en intérim
alors oui il y a urgence au delà de la
technique
au delà de la nécessaire approche
juridique je vous dirais quelques mots
par rapport aux mesures proposées
transféré des milliers des millions même
de mètres carrés de bureaux vides en
logements
c'est de l'urgence et c'est du bon sens
limité les obligations réglementaires en
matière de stationnement à proximité des
transports en commun c'est urgent et ses
tubes haut c'est du bon sens favoriser
la densification pour éviter l'étalement
urbain en permettant la surélévation
d'immeubles dans les zones où la demande
est forte
c'est urgent également et c'est aussi du
bon sens
raccourcir les procédures
administratives afin de permettre
l'émergence de plus de projets quand il
y en a besoin et là où il y en a besoin
c'est aussi plus de bon sens et enfin je
le dis aussi en tant qu elques en tant
qu'écologiste lutter contre les recours
lorsqu'ils sont abusifs malveillants
intéressés directement voire mafieux
c'est également du bon sens maintenant
il faut pas abuser non plus dans l'autre
sens la reconnaissance des associations
reconnues reconnu nationalement pour le
rôle qu'elle joue et qu'elles ont un
talent à jouer et à continuer de jouer
dans la mesure où elles ne sont pas dans
la musique également alors autant de
mesures de bon sens qui ne peuvent
qu'aller dans le bon sens et c'est une
nécessité aujourd'hui n'est qu'une étape
qui s'inscrit dans des perspectives de
plus long terme celle de structurer le
territoire d'utiliser l'urbanisme pour
reconquérir les espaces urbains
délaissés aussi de créer ou de recréer
du vivre ensemble de la solidarité
il existe aussi et ce sera à voir dans
le deuxième temps
des localités nombreuses partout sur le
territoire national ou du logement
il y en a du beau logement patrimoniale
fermer ces territoires
le président nezar les avait évoqué tout
à l'heure sont des sondés territoire
quelque peu délaissé faute de
perspectives économiques mais aussi
d'équipements et de services publics de
proximité il y a une vie il y à des
espaces de vie au delà des grandes
agglomérations
au delà des grandes villes au delà des
grandes métropoles
il importe que nous en ayons toujours
conscience une vision de long terme qui
permet de penser les espaces en sortant
des clivage ville-campagne de penser des
espaces durable où s'équilibrent densité
préservation des espaces remarquables
gestion de flux gestion des ressources
gestion des déchets il s'agit
d'organiser la transition écologique de
l'aménagement de notre territoire et ce
afin de concilier production de
logements et d'équipements et lutter
contre l'artificialisation des sols pour
tenir l'objectif d'un sol nat 2 0 terres
agricoles consommée par la remise par
l'urbanisation à terme il s'agit aussi
d'organiser le changement en profondeur
du secteur de la production de la
production du long de logements en
favorisant l'utilisation de matériaux
innovants performants issus de matières
renouvelables ou recyclés ou bien pour
bâtir et donc mieux en disent anticiper
les mutations à venir qualité du bâti
tant esthétiques durable qualité du
paysage en ville et des espaces publics
préservation de la nature en ville pour
une cause d'une cohabitation heureuse
entre l'humain et la biodiversité selon
le concept suédois des socios top qui
sont qui sont des concepts extrêmement
heureux et qui fonctionne bien votre
projet de loi urbanisme et logement
prévu pour la rentrée sera donc celui
d'un grand pas vers la nécessaire
transition et c'est là une excellente
chose pour le secteur du bâtiment je
l'évoqué tout à l'heure et que ce
secteur se saisissent de cette
opportunité pour repenser un modèle
économique
plus viable et plus durable votre projet
devra également être l'occasion de
repenser la relation entre propriétaires
et locataires
enfin j'y suis très attaché pour ce qui
concerne les modes de vie alternatifs
notre société est vivante de la
multitude des utopies et des choix qui
sont faits par certains
plus d'un million de nos concitoyens ont
fait le choix de vivre différemment que
ce soit l'habitat participatif sur
lequel vous vous êtes déjà intéressé
madame la ministre de l'habitat
coopératif de l'habitat léger aussi qui
pose problème pour lequel on devra
trouver des solutions qui loin d'être un
épiphénomène ou un pis-aller face à une
situation de crise marquent le choix de
vie d'un certain nombre croissant de
personnes
il est donc nécessaire de faire évoluer
le cadre législatif pour permettre la
reconnaissance de mode de vie alternatif
vous l'aurez compris madame la ministre
nous voterons avec force le texte qui
nous a présenté aujourd'hui et nous
serons avec vous derrière le
gouvernement pour soutenir un grand
projet de loi à venir qui donne le droit
à vivre pour tous dans la dignité et
qu'au delà de la technique et du
juridique votre projet puisse
réenchanter nos villes et nos campagnes
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
dans la discussion générale la parole
était monsieur françois calvet pour 20
minutes de la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
c'est la troisième fois en quelques mois
que le parlement est saisi d'un texte
relatif au logement et à la construction
vous avez commencer par abroger le
dispositif relatif à la majoration des
droits à construire avant même son
entrée en vigueur et sans proposer
aucune alternative
nous constatons qu'aujourd'hui vous
souhaitez dans l'urgence et dans le même
esprit promouvoir la densification de
l'habitat mais dans les seules zones
tendues nous aurions pu discuter de ses
mesures
à l'occasion de cette loi d'abrogation
au lieu d'en faire un symbole de la
table rase du passé
puis nous avons discuté à deux reprises
pour cause de mes connaissances de la
procédure parlementaire d'un texte dont
le seul résultat tangible sera comme
annoncée d'imposer une amende majorée
dès 2014 à la très grande majorité des
communes qui ne pourront atteindre le
quota de 25 % de logements sociaux d'ici
en effet ce projet de loi qui devait
être le texte fondateur de la
mobilisation du foncier public en faveur
du logement social était si urgent que
nous sommes toujours dans la tente de
connaître les terrains susceptibles
d'être libéré il se confirme donc bien
que l'urgence consistait d'abord dans la
création d'un nouvel impôt sur les
communes
aujourd'hui vous nous présenter un
projet de loi d'habilitation du
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnances
au motif que vous souhaitez aller plus
vite
alors que vous nous annoncez déjà un
projet de loi
de plus d'une centaine d'articles pour
le mois de juillet d'urgence en urgence
nous
vous donnez le sentiment d'une véritable
agitation législative et politique dans
les résultats se former se feront
attendre vous nous déclare y est
pourtant madame la ministre en septembre
2012 dans cet hémicycle sur la méthode
du précédent gouvernement qu'il ne
fallait pas confondre vitesse et
précipitation détermination et agitation
ne serait ce qu'en termes de méthode
vous disiez ce gouvernement tout en
prenant les sujets à bras le corps ne
travaillera pas de cette manière
depuis nous constatons en effet un vrai
problème de méthode de votre
gouvernement et nous cherchons comme
tous les français
vainement de comprendre à la fois la
méthode et la direction
notre première remarque concerne la
méthode utilisée ils étaient autant
après avoir fait campagne sur la
normalité que le président de la
république ce rallye dans le nouvel
hebdomadaire tendance par la grâce
présidentielle aux vertus des
ordonnances le président de la
république déclarait récemment dans
paris match c'est une grande leçon de la
première année de mon quinquennat
le temps des processus législatif et
réglementaire n'est plus adapté autant
de l'avis des français il faut aller
plus vite
pourtant je me souviens en 2005 dans une
autre vie et dans un autre hémicycle le
député de la corrèze dénoncé à
l'assemblée nationale à propos de
l'habilitation à légiférer par
ordonnance une méthode détestable
jugeant que légiférer par ordonnances
revenait à flouer le parlement et a
renoncé à la confrontation démocrate
démocratique au et et aux débats et aux
débats serrés ce mec pardon même si je
ne partage pas cette hostilité au retour
du recours aux ordonnances
il doit demeurer une exception dans
notre processus démocratique
mais aujourd'hui nous nous interrogeons
sur la justification de l'urgence de ce
projet d'habitation à légiférer par
ordonnance en effet vous avez perdu
plusieurs mois sur un texte précédent
qui était
tout aussi urgent et à ce jour les
décrets d'application de ce texte ne
sont pas sortis vous savez très bien
vous savez très bien qu'entre la
décision de construire la sortie de
terre il se passe entre 18 et 24 mois
quand tout va bien et surtout vous avez
annoncé un grand texte fondateur pour le
mois de juillet dans deux jours nous
serons au mois de juin
si nous prenons en compte les délais
prévus par l'article 2 du projet de loi
d'habilitation
il est très probable que ces ordonnances
soit effective au moment du vote final
de la prochaine loi le gouvernement ne
perdrait t-il pas moins de temps à nous
proposer une seule réforme cohérente
l'autre inquiétude concernant
l'utilisation des ordonnances est
toujours celle de l'inflation des normes
sur lesquels il sera quasiment
impossible de revenir puisqu'il faudra
passer par la loi
le président de la république a
récemment annoncé un choc de
simplification et nous réclamons tous en
tant qu'élus locaux une simplification
de la réglementation et des normes en
matière d'urbanisme et je n'arrive pas
un instant à croire que huit nouvelles
ordonnances vont aboutir à des
simplifications l' ordonnance est un ver
here est un véhicule parfait pour faire
passer les mesures tiroirs des
administrations compétentes ou les
mesures sectorielles qui n'apparaissent
pas comme tel le parlement n'a pas les
moyens ni le temps de mesurer les
conséquences de cette logorrhée
législatives dont nous sommes à la fois
les acteurs et les victimes
en tant qu'élu local aussi malgré la
bonne volonté dont vous nous assurez
madame la ministre
et nous avons pris content de vous
engager à nous informer en amont du
contenu de ces ordonnances
nous savons que cette procédure
ressemble à s'y méprendre à un blanc
seing du parlement à tout le moins une
ordonnance ratifiée
peut-on faire l'objet d'une question
préalable d'un coach
unité nous serons donc attentifs aux
procédures au processus de ratification
j'en viens à ma deuxième remarque sur la
direction prise par le gouvernement en
matière de logement qui pose de la
question de la cohérence de votre
politique
la cohérence c'est aussi celle des choix
comment pensez vous que les communes
vont pouvoir financer des logements
intermédiaires
quand la plupart d'entre elles à partir
de 2014 ne devront réaliser que les
logements sociaux pour atteindre les
objectifs triennaux fixé par votre
précédente loi qui impose 25 % de
logements sociaux en 2025 quelle place
restera-t-il pour le logement
intermédiaire quand vous condamnez les
collectivités à concentrer tous les
efforts sur le seul logement social vous
voulez promouvoir par ordonnance une
offre diversifiée de logements locatifs
que vous condamnez dans une loi
précédente en imposant 25 % des
logements des communes en habitat social
nous notons d'ailleurs que l'article 2
de la loi du 18 janvier 2013 prévoit
dans un délai de six mois après la
promulgation de la loi que vous devez
remettre au parlement un rapport sur les
modalités de mise en oeuvre de la règle
dite des trois tiers bâti un tiers de
logements sociaux un tiers de logements
intérêts intermédiaire un tiers de
logements libres
peut-être pourriez-vous nous dire madame
la ministre ou année ce rapport qui doit
émettre des recommandations pour définir
une stratégie d'intervention d'ici le 19
juillet prochain
autre sujet de cohérence dans votre
politique
vous voulez grâce à ces ordonnances
encourager la construction mais vous
commencez par augmenter le coût par le
biais de l'augmentation de la tva
il est vrai qu'il est annoncé que la tva
applicable au logement social sera amené
à 5% mais vous n'atteindrez pas 500
mille logements construits par an en
comptant sur la seule réalisation de
logements sociaux
et quelles que soient les mesures prises
l'augmentation du taux de la tva sur la
construction privée est un vrai frein à
toute relance du bâtiment est un mauvais
signal pour le secteur j'en viens au 8
ordonnance que vous proposez pour
accélérer la construction de logements
et la réalisation de projets d'intérêts
généraux vous allez créer une procédure
intégrer des délais raccourcis sont
prévues dans le cadre des différentes
étapes d'instruction du projet
permettant ainsi de regrouper les
autorisations repris requise nous ne
pouvons qu'encourager cette volonté la
seconde ordonnance vise à créer un
portail national de l'urbanisme
ce qui nous paraît une bonne idée sous
réserve des délais souvent extrêmement
long de mise en oeuvre opérationnelle de
ce type d'outil nationaux qui ne
correspondent pas à l'urgence de la
situation
je voudrais ajouter mais nous avait fait
part de l'aide qui sera apportée aux
communes du coût non négligeable pour
les petites communes de cette obligation
nous ne sommes pas opposés au relèvement
du taux de garantie que les
collectivités locales peuvent apporter
au projet c'est une mesure intéressante
dans une
dans un contexte de restriction de
crédit bancaire mais pouvez-vous nous
assurer que les collectivités
territoriales ne seront pas pénalisés
par les banques et les agences de
notation quand elles demanderont une
empreinte pour d'autres projets les
organismes bancaires regarde avec une
acuité croissante
le poids des garanties pour les
collectivités cette garantie que vous
souhaitez mettre en place va t'elle
rentrer dans les rations galère il est
difficile aujourd'hui d'anticiper les
conséquences de la mesure que vous
proposez mais qui rappelle combien la
situation budgétaire des collectivités
publiques en france et précaires vous
proposer des mesures visant à accélérer
le règlement des recours contentieux et
endiguer les recours abusifs en matière
durban
nice mme nous avons dénoncée à de
nombreuses reprises ces recours
systématique qui gangrènent la vie de
nos collectivités et entravent le
développement de nos territoires
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il s'agit
là d'un domaine où la rédaction du texte
sera particulièrement importante et d un
débat en commission nous a permis de
noter les choses extrêmement précise et
donc il faut que les délais de
contentieux soient réduits tout en
préservant bien sûr les droits de chacun
la 5ème ordonnance suscite une véritable
inquiétude parmi les maires qui
s'interroge sur les conditions de
dérogation aux plans locaux d'urbanisme
au motif de densification urbaine
il nous semble qu'en matière
d'aménagement urbain
seules les villes sont en mesure de
définir leurs besoins et leurs attentes
déroger aux règles fixées par le conseil
municipal où la communauté
d'agglomération ne doit à ne doit pas
pouvoir se faire sans l'accord des élus
j'ai noté que dans nos discussions en
commission et vous même lorsque vous
nous auditionnés vous avez pris en
compte cet argument mais je veux encore
le souligner concernant la
transformation de bureaux à logements
plusieurs mesures ont déjà été prises en
ce sens par le passé cela n'a jamais
vraiment fonctionné et je ne crois pas
que le nouveau texte change grand chose
en période de crise où le nombre de taz
de transactions s'effondre et où les
prix du marché sont à la baisse
personne ne veut prendre le risque d'une
transformation coûteuse dont la revente
ou la rentabilité locative demeure
aléatoire
je rappelle que le nombre de ventes de
logements anciens s'est établi à 709 me
en 2012 en baisse de 12% sur un an si on
exclut le nombre élevé de mutation en
janvier 2012
motivé par le changement de régime
d'imposition des plus values
immobilières à partir de février le
nombre des mutations diminue de 22% 2
au cours des douze mois précédents selon
l'observatoire crédit logement csa
la distribution du crédit à l'habitat
des ménages est également en recul de
27,2 % à fin février 2013 en rythme
annuel quelle entreprise ou quelle
institution va prendre un tel risque de
transformer des locaux de bureaux
souvent très anciens un logement dans ce
contexte
d'ailleurs le gouvernement est conscient
de la hausse du risque immobilier
puisque vous proposer avec raison de
supprimer la garantie intrinsèque pour
les opérations de vente en l'état futur
d'achèvement briques
tout n'est pas négatif concernant le
logement intermédiaire je me suis déjà
exprimé
nous sommes très favorables à la mixité
de l'habitat urbain et avant de dénoncer
le risque d'effets de guerre cotisation
de ghettos de votre précédente loi mais
votre loi visant à imposer 25 % de
logements sociaux sous peine d'amendés
majoré par c'est rendra inefficace
votre volonté nouvelle de favoriser les
logements intermédiaires si ceux-ci ne
rentre pas dans le quota des 25%
vous ne pouvez pas fixer de nouveaux
objectifs qu aucune commune ne sera en
mesure de tenir
vous réalisez que vous avez oublié les
classes moyennes qui n'ont ni accès au
logement social ni accès au logement
privé
c'est une bonne nouvelle à condition de
desserrer le carcan du logement social
que vous avez imposé aux communes
enfin vous proposer de modifier les
règles sur les délais de paiement des
entreprises du bâtiment qui sont
nombreuses à connaître des difficultés
de trésorerie
c'est certainement une bonne mesure mais
je ne crois pas son efficacité la france
doit être championne du monde en nombre
de loi sur les délais de paiement depuis
30 ans
toujours pour le même motif ces lois
n'ont malheureusement jamais changé la
précarité des tpe françaises en matière
de trésorerie n'est leur manque récurent
de fonds propres la réalité c'est que la
france n'a pas de tissu d'entreprises de
taille moyenne suffisamment solides pour
survivre à une crise aujourd'hui les
entreprises les plus solides qu'ils
n'ont plus de marché accepte les petits
marchés de rénovation casse souvent les
prix et tu le tissu des tpe une énième
réforme des délais de paiement ne
changera rien surtout quand elle ne
touchera que les marchés privés
quand ce sont les collectivités
publiques qui paie avec le plus de
retard le sujet des marchés privés
aujourd'hui n'est plus de savoir à
quelle date l'entreprise sera réglé mais
bien s'il réussira à se faire payer
je voudrais vous dire en conclusion que
ces ordonnance motivée par l'urgence de
la situation de la construction ne
pourrons résoudre est le seul la crise
que nous traversons
sur les deux premiers mois de l'année le
nombre de logements neufs mis en
chantier ne s'élève qu'à 50 de 1750
unités contre 63 1430 sur la même
période en 2012 soit un recul de l'ordre
de 16%
le nombre de permis de construire
accordés en 2012 a diminué de 7,3 pour
cent un angle et de 24,1 pour ça sur
leucate le seul quatrième trimestre sur
l'emmener 2012 l'insee estime une perte
d'emploi pour le bâtiment de 22 mille
trois cents emplois dans le secteur
dans ce secteur et il est probable que
l'année 2013 soit bien pire la situation
chers collègues est suffisamment grave
pour que nous vous laissions toutes les
chances de réussir et le bénéfice du
doute quant à la réalité du contenu de
ces ordonnances et aux orientations du
futur projet de loi
pour ces raisons le groupe ump
s'abstiendra sur ce texte
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette science si
vous souhaitez la revoir elle est
disponible en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr bonne soirée à
tous